even before families get together for
the holidays we are seeing a surge in
coronavirus numbers
over the past three days alone the u.s
reported more than 517
thousand new cases which puts the total
since the start of this pandemic above
12 million americans
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in sioux falls south dakota
very unique place these days david good
morning to you
just how bad is it there well over the
last 24 hours south dakota reported
42 new covet related deaths 42.
now a health expert here in south dakota
says per capita over the last week south
dakota has reported more covid related
deaths
than any other state in the country
consider this you know how some people
say oh covet affects folks just like the
regular flu
here in south dakota on average every
year they have 48
flu related deaths 48 they had 42
coveted related deaths in just one day
south dakotans do not want to be told
what to do
especially when it comes to wearing a
mask just ask the mayor of sioux falls
paul tenhacan this is cowboy country man
and you try and tell someone to do
something
and they want to do the opposite as a
result the mayor resisted a mass mandate
for months
but the city finally passed one and over
the weekend it took effect
but there is no penalty for those who
refuse to wear one
we're at a bar without a mouse most
people we saw in the downtown area of
bars and restaurants
were not sioux falls is putting in a
restriction on themselves but
like south dakotan in general doesn't
care at all
whether or not there's a mass mandate or
any restrictions to
help covet at all twenty-two-year-old
nicole noshaw was about to enter a bar
when she agreed
to speak with us and admitted honestly
i am an rn on a covid unit
i don't mean to put you on the spot but
you know you are an rn
yeah you work in a covet unit right
nobody gets it better than you
and here you are coming to party without
a mast i've had it but that doesn't mean
that
like i do care about other people and
like
their health as well for the record the
two women decided not to go into the bar
after our interview
even the leader of sanford health the
largest health system in the dakotas
has given people reason to question
whether there is a crisis here
it's hard for me to say we are at a
crisis that would be misleading
from a clinical standpoint but ceo kelby
krabenhoff
isn't a doctor his chief medical officer
dr
allison suttle is would you classify
what is happening here in the dakotas
as a crisis i would one expert in south
dakota
says the state has the highest
hospitalizations per capita
in the country do you believe that the
governor of south dakota
should put a masked mandate in place i
do believe that the governor should put
a mass mandate in place that that would
help us
in our attempt to fight this virus the
governor has vowed not to
you know south dakotans preach personal
responsibility
when it comes to how we pass this
infection i think that we need to step
up
and say that this is not the police or
law enforcement's problem this is ours
and every massless person we spoke to
seemed to not only know better
but they vowed to do better i came out
of a bar where no one's wearing masks
but i believe in wearing masks and i'm
not wearing one so i feel like a giant
piece of crap
for not wearing one so now that young
man knows that there is a mask mandate
in effect here in sioux falls statewide
the republican governor
has resisted for months she says i'm not
going to institute a mass mandate though
her republican governor in north dakota
just did south dakota's governor gail
said listen
we are not going to stop you or
discourage you
from thanking god or spending time
together this thanksgiving
boy david i'm so glad that the rn nurse
decided that she wasn't going to go into
the bar you could see while you were
talking to her her face was like this is
a bad idea talking to you about this
so i'm so glad that she turned around
and didn't go in yeah that's very good
news thank you david